All Aboard for zero carbon bus travel
it's all about hydrogen
[Music]
welcome to the show and we're all about
hydrogen and big vehicles this bus is
just one of part of the biggest rollout
of hydrogen buses in Europe
also on the show Thomas Moore gets taken
out for a spin in a hydrogen-fueled
lorry is it the future of green Trucking
I speak to the climate minister of one
of the planet's most vulnerable Nations
to climate change and he has a message
for our government we will be putting
extra scrutiny on the UK government to
ensure they continue to fulfill their
commitments and it's the weekend so I'm
having a point this Brewery thinks it's
made one that's truly carbon negative
cheers but first a lot of people think
electricity is the answer to
climate-friendly transport but this
place is betting the fleet on hydrogen
is this the future of zero emission bus
travel this operator in Sussex certainly
thinks so betting big on hydrogen power
over battery electric by the end of next
year 54 will be on the roads the largest
Fleet in Europe
but zero emission hydrogen is expensive
to produce hi welcome for Tom I want to
thank you and many experts say electric
vehicles are a better choice why have
you decided to go for this technology
with hydrogen we will get about 300
miles a day out of the bus when if you
look at battery electric we might get
180 to 200 so when looking at it for the
Fastway route it was critical that we
could get a full day's worth of
operation with the bus going out at
three in the morning and potentially
coming back at one in the morning very
long operational days which is why we
needed hydrogen safe compared with
battery electric I guess these buses are
more expensive that's presumably a bit
of a problem isn't it the buses are
significantly more expensive than a
standard diesel bus so we're looking at
about 500 000 pounds to this bus when a
conventional diesel bus is around 270.
so will it be any more expensive for
people to ride on no no more expensive
for people to ride on you think that'll
make a measurable difference to the air
quality around cruel oh yeah yeah over
time it will all add up if we haven't
got a diesel bus out every day and we're
producing nothing more than water at the
tailpipe it'll make a huge difference
over time so every little step can take
is going to make a big difference in in
you know improving air quality the fast
way route linking Crawley to Gatwick
runs 24 hours a day 365 days a year the
switch to hydrogen will save over 36
tons of carbon dioxide a week for
something quite revolutionary in terms
of pollution and climate change it looks
fairly normal and the drivers say it
goes much like a normal bus except it
has that acceleration you associate with
electric vehicles because the hydrogen
is making electricity on board and it's
that that drives the wheels one thing I
really like on the dash instead of a
fuel gauge you can see an H2 gauge
and the drivers here are certainly
convinced it's going to change the world
I think hydrogen's the way forward and
ranges there I think electric buses just
don't aren't the way forward for us
anyway
um but yeah been be interesting to see
where zero Mission goes but in my view
is the way forward buses and coaches
make up three percent of our Total
Transport emissions so rolling out
carbon-free Vehicles is an easy way to
cut those emissions and improve air
quality too it's like hearing an
automatic um
the government's committed to having
thousands on the road before the next
election but with concerns over hydrogen
Supply and efficiency how much of a role
will it really play I think hydrogen has
definitely got a big role to play
particularly with those heavier uh HUV
Vehicles some of the Earth moving
equipment as well why is the hydrogen
coming from Holland that suggests we
haven't really got our hydrogen
infrastructure in a good place well we
do need to do more on that that's
definitely true the government's got a
big energy renewable energy strategy
coming out this summer I'm desperate to
see more production here in the UK and
there is definitely a way we can use
some of our renewable energy sector to
help generate some of that green
hydrogen as well you've committed to
four thousand zero emission buses by the
end of this Parliament how many have we
got so far so you've got over three and
a half 3 400 have been funded and there
are hundreds on the road already and
we've been in separate hundreds on the
road you've got to get a four thousand
by the way we're going to get there
we're going to get there I'm absolutely
convinced we're going to get there so
whether electric hydrogen or a bit of
both the way is clear for cleaner buses
I think our heavy trucks Skies Thomas
More has been to see one of the first
hydrogen-powered hgvs in action
Net Zero has a heavyweight problem how
to power all the lorries on our roads
without producing greenhouse gases but
this may be one solution the first
British designed and built prototype
fueled with hydrogen and all that comes
out of the tailpipe is water
you don't have the Roar of the diesel
engine you don't have the fumes of the
diesel engine more importantly but yeah
it's quite a it's a nice place to live
and work
it has a range of 370 miles not far
short of a traditional diesel hgv to
match that an electric truck would need
a battery weighing several tons and that
would mean carrying less Freight the
benefits of hydrogen Stack Up say the
manufacturers a hydrogen vehicle takes
15 to 20 minutes to the fuel and it's
ready to go again unfortunately battery
electric vehicles can take up to five to
six hours through the fuel which is
downtime for Fleet operators and they
cannot have that because the margins are
so tight exactly
hgvs only make up 1.5 of all the
vehicles on the road that produce almost
20 percent of carbon emissions from
transport the government has said it
will stop sales of all new diesel
lorries by 2040.
but there's no plan on how to do that
and not a single electric or hydrogen
refueling point for trucks on the road
Network
if you're a fleet manager you need to
plan ahead what vehicles you are going
to be adopting so it is a tight timeline
we need the government to be moving
quicker with trials while we need that
plan for how infrastructure is going to
be put in place to reassure operators
that as they plan their future Vehicles
they know that it is going to be
supported by the right infrastructure
the government will shortly announce
Road Trials of zero emission trucks that
could even be tests of overhead wires on
motorways a system already being looked
at it in Germany the downside to
hydrogen is that making it from Green
electricity is at the moment inefficient
and expensive scientists calculate that
it would take something like 3 000 big
offshore wind turbines to make enough of
the gas to power all the hgvs on our
roads more than doubling the average
annual electricity consumption for the
whole country but Advocates of hydrogen
are confident that technology will
become more efficient producing the gas
at scale to keep the wheels turning
Thomas More Sky News in Warwickshire
well to talk through what role hydrogen
has with our heavier Vehicles I'm joined
by Helena Bennett from the think tank
green Alliance and David siebon
professor of engineering from Cambridge
who specializes in decarbonizing Freight
so from those two films Helen we've very
clearly heard the message that hydrogen
should be part of the answer for heavy
things on the road what do you ring so
hydrogen is really interesting because
at the moment there's not loads of
supply of hydrogen especially low carbon
clean hydrogen so we have to be really
careful about where we think we want to
use it and it's currently being used in
a few different places fertilizer for
example and there are parts of the
economy that are going to need hydrogen
really desperately to decarbonize with
things like heavy heavy transport so
trucks and buses there are alternatives
to hydrogen so electrification actually
is a much better use of the energy than
hydrogen is and we're seeing a lot of
electric buses being rolled out at the
moment and we're seeing a lot of
development in the hydrogen truck sector
as well David we heard from from the
people Behind These buses that electric
just didn't work for them because they
had so far to go so for them as a user
hydrogen is the answer and I guess some
hauliers might say the same uh
electricity is perfect for buses right
electric buses are being rolled out all
around the world I've spoken to one of
my partners today just bought 600
electric buses in Delhi
there's thousands and thousands electric
buses around the world hydrogen buses
are having a pretty poor show uh there
was uh uh
30 million euro order of hydrogen buses
in lausanne and France canceled last
year because the buses turned out to be
six times more expensive than electric
buses right so even when the distance is
a long which was their point they're
Crawley even when the distance is along
you can easily get hundreds of miles of
range from an electric bus and there's
all kinds of options particularly Urban
buses there's all kinds of options for
charging them at either end of the line
or swapping buses out in the middle of
the day so we're seeing electric buses
really taking over and hydrogen buses
are really not going to do very well
they're very expensive hydrogen buses
are nearly double the cost of electric
buses and they cost at least three times
more to run
is it fair that we should have an
ecosystem that isn't either or but does
have both or is that just kind of
dodging the difficult decision I think
and the problem is investment in things
like hydrogen buses today as David
highlighted could mean stranded Assets
in the future for some councils or
cities that are investing in hydrogen
meaning you buy something and then it
doesn't work well yeah it might not be
economically competitive in the future
even now in fact as David's highlighted
with a few examples of where electric
electric buses are already out competing
hydrogen buses especially somewhere like
the UK we're not a very big island and
actually the range of that you can get
from Big batteries in in buses and
coaches now is completely fit for
purpose for the size of the island that
we are David I've heard you explain why
hydrogen is relatively inefficient as an
NG Source can you give me a kind of
potted version of that well the problem
is that when you you take electricity
which is really high quality energy when
you make it into hydrogen you make it
into a much lower grade of energy and
that energy when you convert it back
into work to push the bus along it only
gives you about 30 percent of what you
started with so you start with you know
100 and by the time you've gone through
this process of making hydrogen and
compressing it storing it and all that
stuff putting it into a fuel cell you've
only got about 25 or 30 left so that
means you've wasted uh at least
two-thirds of the of the energy and you
have to pay for that energy that is
wasted and that's why it's so expensive
because you don't get much out for what
you pay
but LML hydrogen is storable and there
are times when we're turning off our
wind turbines because they're making too
much uh electricity would there be an
argument for saying instead of
curtailing our electricity our wind
turbines we should be making that into
hydrogen uh there there is an argument
for that yeah so that's that's more
about the production of hydrogen rather
than the end use of it which is what
this discussion about buses is is really
about and I think it's at the end of the
production comes into it on the
efficiency thing that David yes yeah
hydrogen well I think just to be really
clear hydrogen will have very important
uses in decarbonizing special parts of
the economy steel and heavy Industries
especially
um I think we think there are some uses
in things like fuel for Aviation for
long distance
um sustainable aviation fuel so just
very briefly hydrogen got a place for
moving stuff along the roads yes or no
uh in most cases no okay Helena David
thank you very much indeed we're off to
a break now and afterwards we'll be back
talking to someone from one of the most
climate vulnerable states in the world
[Music]
welcome back to the show and you find me
close to the headquarters of the
international Maritime organization
where a historic deal has just been
thrashed out which for the first time
seeks to limit carbon from shipping and
this really matters because emissions
from Shipping are about three percent of
total man-made carbon emissions
well I'm joined Now by Ralph vegan vanu
who's a climate adaptation energy and
environment minister of Vanuatu one of
the often called vulnerable Pacific
island States what was agreed on
emissions from shipping and does it go
far enough to satisfy you so what was
agreed here of the IMO in London is
the first time ever that we have a
greenhouse gas emission strategy a
decarbonization of shipping the
international shipping industry all
countries in the world agreed to
decarbonize shipping with certain
targets using certain mechanisms by
certain dates and just briefly what kind
of techniques are they using because I
mean are they going to change the way
ships are fueled or is it offsetting
what what's in mind so there's a fuel
standard
that has to be agreed a fuel standard
with far lower
carbon and also of course all in taking
out all the alternative fuels because
now you have alternative non-carbon
fuels available for ships like hydrogen
like biofuels so setting a standard that
the industry can take as a direction on
the kind of fuels it needs to develop
and the kind of ships it needs to
develop that are going to use those
fuels to achieve this Net Zero by 2050.
did it go far enough for you
what happened here didn't go as far
enough as we were coming here hoping for
with our level of ambition but what we
have with the especially with the
targets agreed to
we feel that the 1.5 degrees Celsius
trajectory that came out of the Paris
agreement is still Within Reach it will
require the highest level of ambition
right now and urgency and really
implementing the measures effectively
and urgently but if we get that highest
level of action now going forward and
that's something that we'll be pushing
we can keep 1.5 Within Reach we often
talk about Vanuatu as being a vulnerable
uh specific State what does that mean in
practice how kind of vulnerable are you
the United Nations classes Vanuatu was
one of the most vulnerable countries in
the world perhaps the top three that
means that we experience all the climate
change impacts which is increasing
intensity and frequency of cyclones
increasing intensity of heavy rainfall
flash flood events all these sort of
things
also because we are on the Pacific Ring
of Fire we get all the volcanoes and
earthquakes and Technology tectonic
geo-hazards uh also because uh we are a
very poor country we used to be one of
the least developed countries of the
world now we are at the bottom of the
developing country rangit means our
capacity to respond
to these disasters is not as good as it
would be if we were a developed country
and so that package of extreme
vulnerability naturally plus very low
Financial capacity makes us one of the
most vulnerable countries to climate
change
we're in the heart of Westminster here
close to the nerve center of the British
government and there's been a lot of
suggestion recently that the British
government has kind of lost its
leadership role on the international
stage when it comes to climate what do
you think
I think the um
recent resignation by Lord Zach
Goldsmith
has put a focus back on the leadership
of the UK and I'm very encouraged by the
response of the government that it is in
fact not reneging on its pledge for
climate finance and it started to
indicate how it's going to possibly meet
it yeah let's just dig into that a bit
of people who don't know so there was a
page I think it's many many billion
pounds it is 11 billion pounds
11.6 billion to help out with climate
Finance Lord Goldsmith suggested that
the government was moving away from that
some other commentators have as well
government's denied it you think that
they're going to stick with it do you
I think there's much more uh Spotlight
on the UK government right now because
of what Lord Goldsmith did and I think
the responses we're getting from the
government show that they've got renewed
Vigor to stick with and Implement that
figure and really there's going to be a
difficulty in in providing it and that
was what Lord Goldsmith is talking about
and really I it really now rests on the
Prime Minister and the chancellor to
make sure they Implement that in full as
the rest of us are expecting them to do
I
than that in the last year or so have
you felt there's been a little bit of a
drift away from being at the center of
the climate argument from the UK
government
it's been a very difficult last 12
months but I know that here at the IMO
the UK was right there in terms of the
highest ambition they were with us the
Pacific and I was really glad to see
that in the IMO itself I think a cop uh
there was really high ambition at
Glasgow two years ago
last year in Shamil Sheikh we started to
see that wine and it was quite a
disappointing cop for us yeah so it's
good to come to IMO and see the UK right
up the front again and we hope that'll
be translated into what we've seen going
into cop the strikes we like you've got
your eye on them you're keeping watch is
that fair we're definitely giving a very
close watch on what the UK does because
the UK has professed itself to be a
climate Champion a high ambition uh
partner and especially now with um you
know Lord Goldsmith was a great Champion
for the climate and for the environment
and especially now that he's gone we
will be putting extra scrutiny on the UK
government to ensure they continue to
fulfill their commitments Ralph Reagan
vanu thank you very much indeed thank
you
well now an update on the story we
brought you a few months ago about
temperate rainforests we went to
Dartmoor and met guy shrubsol who's
seeking to protect these vital
ecosystems well now guy has had a
significant win with a very Royal
landowner
so whisman's wood is a wonderful
fragment of temperate rainforests high
up on Dartmoor an amazing Atlantic
Oakwood of null old ancient oak trees
dripping with lichens and mosses and all
the things that characterize a temperate
rainforest in Britain but it's very very
small just eight acres in size so what's
been wonderful this week has been the
announcement of a plan by the landowner
the duchy of Cornwall owned by Prince
William working with their tenant farmer
and with natural England to regenerate
and expand Richmond's wood and the plan
is to Simply allow the wood to expand
Naturally by restricting certain forms
of grazing by sheep and the plan is to
double the size of wisman's wood by 2040
which is absolutely fantastic
now it's been a long week and I could do
with a drink luckily I'm right outside a
brewery that's making a point or two
that claimed to be carbon negative
while it may not look like it this point
is a little bit different Brewers here
in South London believe it's the first
carbon negative Point without using any
offsets like tree planting
possibly too early I've got a hernage
um why have you done this yeah we've
made this product because we want to
make great tasting beers that are
helping solve our climate crisis can you
show me how it's done yeah let's have a
look
the secret is in the barley they're
using this is the ballet that we used to
make the beer it's been grown in fields
with polycrops three different crops
there's no tilling there's no pesticides
herbicides none of that it's natural
when it comes to climate change what's
the difference between this barley and
normal so normal Bali per day for us has
of common footprint of about one ton of
CO2 whereas this barley has a comfort
print of minus seven tons great for the
ingredients all about the process let's
go and see
um we've got an innovation that we're
doing next door which is recapturing the
Hops that we use so the beer is coming
through this machine and it's separating
out the Hops from the beer and creating
this dry powder work
so those are hops that have been used
already when we use hops we generally
grow half of it away like an orange cut
it in half we choose one half we'll
throw the other half away we're just
capturing that other half and making
sure we use that too
reducing the carbon intensity of beer
needs attention from growing of the
ingredients all the way through to the
brewing and the packaging and that's why
it's such a hard goal to reach Ben has
crunched the numbers what is carbon
negative here and what isn't yeah just
the beer and the kegs as a packaging
type at the moment is carbon negative
we're looking to roll that out across
the cans and the beer and the cans as
well but it's going to take some changes
to packaging style and operationally to
get that down so what is it that makes
the the kegs carbon negative and
potentially not the cows yeah so kegs
beer kegs are actually reusable so
they're just washed out and cleaned
comparatively to the cans that have to
be recycled which is energy intensive
which subsequently means a mission
intensive as well
I promised I'll be back
this beer is 10 more expensive so is the
demand there it's not just this Brewery
they're doing this we've seen some big
Brewers getting on this act they must
think there's an advantage there yes
certainly I think moving towards carbon
neutral or moving towards carbon
negative is something which is going to
be increasingly important for breweries
the government have got set legal
targets by 2050 for all businesses to be
net zero emissions do we know if
customers are prepared to pay a little
bit more for climate friendly beer yet
um I don't know if we know the answer to
that exactly but we're we're certainly
seeing I mean the way that Gypsy Hill
have done it is to be really forward in
the way they're promoting to be you know
they're selling it as a carbon negative
lager they're putting it in there in The
Branding it's about educating consumers
helping them understand why if you use
higher quality ingredients if you use
lower environmental impact ingredients
then that is ultimately going to produce
a better beer but a lower impact beer
that's perhaps worth a bit more money
with breweries now also on the conveyor
belt towards net zero could Greener
pints soon be pulled at your local
well that's it for this week don't worry
just leave me here in the meantime you
can catch up with all your climate and
environment news on the Sky News website
and app or by scanning the QR code that
is on your screen right now I'll be back
next week in Bristol where a new onshore
wind turbine is helping some of the
poorest communities in the meantime
cheers
foreign
[Music]